a lot of playoff action coming up  as john moran staff congratulates steph  curry the respect factor we got a pair  of game threes on friday night on espn  first at seven heat and sixers then at 9  30 suns and the mavericks coverage  begins with nba countdown  at 6 30.  i drama in memphis to start this western  conference semi-final series  the golden state warriors  there's a lot of playoff action coming  up  congratulate steph curry the respect  factor we got a pair of game threes on  friday night on espn first at seven heat  and sixers then at 9 30 suns and the  mavericks coverage begins with nba  countdown at 6 30.  i drama in memphis to start this western  conference semi-final series the golden  state warriors  [Music]